[Aplausos]
boa noite
eu vou falar pra vocês hoje sobre seu
jeito sensual como fonte de poder de
força de força da mulher de força de
humanidade
então eu queria convidar vocês pra
acompanhar uma história que a história
da nossa humanidade e há muitos anos
atrás no início da civilização primeiras
nossas sociedades tv uma grande
admiração
ícones do feminino que tinha a ver com
um é a admiração pela produção e pelo
poder da mulher de rio a vida de doação
a velocidade a sexualidade é a gente
pode ver apresentações é movimentar essa
escultóricas enfim muitas evidências de
que originalmente a mulher sim era
admirada pela própria capacidade de
sexualidade de produção
aí foi logo dizendo que essa imagem ser
mais difícil de mais energia do que
futebol e que ficávamos animais perto de
casa
aí quando as sociedades foram cuidando
do gado e observamos o jeito que eles
atuavam no entanto que eu acho que
colocava semente no na folha
de repente é grande admiração pela
mulher criança será considerada como a
doadora de dívida
de repente apareceu não o masculino finn
haver um homem que tem um poder que o
homem que colocou o seguinte
e aí aos poucos e rapidamente na verdade
foi de ano
o poder
eu usei quando saindo derrotados e
àqueles equipes no feminino os cultos ou
feminino e foram aparecendo ídolos mas
sim tudo certo clima frio foi realmente
passando muito usados muitos anos muitas
mudanças sociais e finalmente a questão
da região que foi deslanchando na
filosofia das culturas nas formas de
pensar na consciência e nosso consciente
também que foi também feito na política
e na economia da sociedade
aí a gente pode dizer que a religião
masculinizou e levou pra uma consciência
tudo trancado o sistema do machismo que
com boninho relação como a questão da
sexualidade
então quando a gente pensar na sua
qualidade a gente vai olhar muito nível
médio agente veja o edital
sabe no próprio nem só de caju e você
vai pra ver tudo mas não é
ei uma questão social uma questão
cultural política social que aconteceu
aos poucos
a mulher então foi virado menos
importante o homem foi pegando mais
força foi assumindo aquele poder e como
era ele que colocava semente na mulher
então volto mais a mulher saber que o
meu antigo então a mulher fui à minha
ficando mais presa mais atingida ela não
podia mais ser indicado a religião foi
crescendo e se aconselhando também do
que é aquela liberdade da mulher
então aí jam que foi deslanchando que
ainda faz uma grande parte do que todo
mundo aqui nesse sociedade mas
do mundo é assim
nem pensar eu to atuando desse jeito de
outro jeito por conta da minha religião
a gente faz a gente já tem bicho do
corpo herança das nossas famílias nossas
gerações anteriores que falta qualidade
é uma coisa suja câncer controlada para
se manter o pulina nem sei então aos
poucos nem a gente tem já duas gerações
de mulheres que não tentaria em casa que
não tem saído em liberdade que eles têm
é ainda não só gostaria em raça que você
escolheu perguntar o que ela sabia
escrever com vida ao contar que farei em
casa a delas a mulher tarde em casa
rodeado de mulheres que poderá ou não
ela e lembrou que era ali o que era já
está ok a mulher foi sendo levada para o
hospital hospital é agora tem mulheres
obviamente enfermeiros médicos mas
originalmente é o nome do dono de ruim
ele o fator casa também o sistema médico
e então o que foi acontecendo contatos e
com sensualidade que é obviamente a
origem aqui levantado foi que a mulher
fui sido tirada de seu poder dela e o
carro fui sendo desvirtuado a mulher não
podia mais escutar vos próprio do que
ele
o ato de farinha de querer fazer um zoom
que quiser de querer se colocar na
posição que ela quiser levar o tempo que
ela precisar
no hospital fui sendo sistematizado um
controle sobre a sexualidade
e aqui a gente vai conseguir um
pouquinho porque eu falo que o fato de
eu ter um evento sexual é um grande
mistério que um sentindo lento pela gina
e que aliás sai pela página crianças
qualidade gente tem alguma coisa a ver
com sexualidade
então tem a ver com sexualidade não só
porque entra pelo design onde sabe se
tudo der certo mas que os hormônios tudo
que tem a ver com a avaliação com tesão
com sensualidade são pessoalmente os
mesmos hormônios que levam para uma
mulher cair
ari um jeito na capital então voltando
pra aquela grande é aquele drama nem de
levar o papa hospital e de controlar a
sensualidade da mulher naquele final
inclusive que o pai lhe deu pra a a
entrada ea instalação cultural do que eu
chamo de cultura do medo ao redor do
paço
eu acho que se a gente for perguntar às
nossas mulheres da família amigas brigas
e não sei se eles vão querer faria
tranquilamente a maioria delas vai falar
em lê lá ele está com medo de que
aconteça algo fundamental porque foi
plantado no medo muito grande porque uma
forma maravilhosa de controlar a mulher
vamos deixar o medo medo da própria nem
a do poder nem do poder que não tem e
quando que a gente se dá conta do poder
ser a trilha que a gente como mulher
temos quando a gente e é encarado e eu
vou falar no feminino por quê
os homens que não conheça o carinho é
isso aí quando a gente encarar a fraco
esse barrigão de nomex já está assim
quase a ponto de explodir paulo
a gente tem que encarar uma sensação de
deus e agora como que eu vou dar conta
de abrir de entregar para trazer essa
vida pra fora
então eu gostaria de falar uma coisa
interessante que aconteceu nos últimos
anos
na minha consciência eu fui pesquisar no
passado sobre temas da sexualidade de
furto de energia só porque como eu sou o
carteiro eo vejo esse carinho
os cursos que o ministro tem tudo a ver
com fazer atua em fazer a consciência da
mulher se acompanhando o pato se dos
homens que acompanha o fatos o respeito
a esse processo do acompanhamento
aí foi encontrar por aí mas alternativas
à pornografia convencional porque eu
queria mostrar as mesmas linhas assim
najas filha de energia sexual é que não
seja só no quarto mas que são antes nem
que eu venho sexual que todo ser humano
todo animal vai ter algum momento na
vida fechado o que eu senti que há
colegas porque a cineasta feminina eo
incentivo à pesquisa
pesquisa pessoal eu usei a beleza
maravilha com emocionantes e mas eu
preciso saber qual é
aqui a outra biografia convencional eu
nunca muito a se ligar ainda aí eu fui
pesquisar e fui olhar é durante dois
dias inteiros sem parar a filmes de
fotografia convencional que nenhum enjoo
e na sensação de querer limitado na
tardia e caiu a ficha caiu entendi que a
versão da biografia felicita o que a
gente a ter essa tentam fazer com a
sexualidade do ano trocou o parto da
mulher que tem haver um respeito como
fechar ela em liberdade
konrath a voz dela a necessidade dela e
que a procura é convencional
me desculpa mas muito claramente tem a
ver com uma linha de obstetrícia
convencional onde a mulher ele usada
como um jeito de pesquisa com 1
ela é colocada uma situação de
desemprego treinamento do ar e sem
entregar a acreditar no que o que o
profissional vai fazer melhor ea 1ª
feira internacional tem isso de que a
mulher é um projeto que tem que se
entregar a um dia tem que deixar
acontecer coisas no corpo dela na alma
dela nem porque o serviço é a energia
vital é emissão é uma vulnerabilidade
muito grande e quando a gente acha que
todo mundo conforta quanto à gestão
deixo com amor com desejo uma um trégua
o beijo vai ser muito gostoso mas o
desde que rumava o beijo que é forçado o
beijo mesmo mesmo
beijo quando não é o teu lento e não é
atender um desejo esse pode ser um
trauma muito grande um evento sexual
quando vêm por de ser louca pode ser a
coisa mais maravilhosa que tem no mundo
uma vez que só forçado violentado
aprendizado pode ser um trauma nem outro
tempo
e o fato é que a gente compreenda que
ele me pede sexual eu climas do que
começou um novo mês antes
só que em grande nave ficado hoje e é
causa de enorme trauma das mulheres
então eu gostaria de colocar umas
imagens pra vocês é já que talvez alguns
de vocês não assistiram ainda um ato que
não seja indeferido revela os atores é
convencional e gostaria de vocês olharem
dessas imagens mantendo uma certa
abertura de fazer uma ligação com
sucesso
então é um convite pra vocês e eu vim
pra aproveitar e mostrar pra vocês um
pouco do que o mundo do parto quando e
no que eu gosto de chamar no habitat
natural que em casa que eu lugar que
geralmente também o acesso é melhor eu
gostaria de imaginar 17 no hospital e
ainda não
então essa imagem
eu espero ter a barriga
uma mulher grávida é isso é o que vai
acontecer
essas imagens são imagens de mulheres
florindo nova parte final dela em
liberdade sem drogas sem anestesia e eu
também gostaria de imaginar qual seria
terceiro com anestesia
eu acho que mesmo time muito porque
essas imagens onde a gente vê mulher
fingindo sentindo profundamente que
passa através do corpo
são momentos onde alguém por fora pode
falar aqui uma dores cristiano tem uma
coisa quase insuportável mas também a
gente não está ouvindo tudo por ter um
atleta que faz a ascensão do fato
gerador
a gente é muito pequena o que a gente
sentir o mar
eu tentei não pode não pode descrever a
sensação de imenso prazer combinado com
uma exposição e um calor e uma
sexualidade
numa cultura onde o sexo é um tabu ea
onde maneira sem ser escondidos das
linhas têm que ser cobertas pelo mic né
aonde a gente acha que a mulher dele
fraca que ela é uma pessoa é por ser
menina ela é muito delicada então parei
de fazer força
olha que a filmagem de força bruta de
força feminina de forçar delicada e
absolutas
a gente não pode ligar o prazer que vem
concedia força na vida de dentro da
gente quando a gente está pagando a
sensação de uma cabeça sair passado e as
pernas da gente eu posso garantir que eu
já falei presidência da minha casa eu
posso continuar
cinema se a justiça decidir um dia a
gente foge descobrir o mato que se não
mesmo essencial chegar e tirar de de
beijar te falar a palavra de amor de
poder descobrir quem eu sou como mulher
fiquei eu sou comunidade por um ser
humano como uma entidade de integridade
total de costa total então e imagem é eu
queria falar sobre o que aconteceu
realmente quando nesses aparelhos
eu vou confessar que não existe a
palavra novo cabo lário atual não existe
a gente tem palavras minúsculas o do
dólar e assim não chega com exceção de
fato tem dor mas quem tantas outras
coisas e outra z faz parte e que você
fosse comer um bolo daqueles fantásticos
de 25 camadas joguei e tato não são 25
toneladas
nenhum é derramado eu lembro aparelho
está sentindo ainda
a cabeça pensando eu quero entrar na áea
a cabeça da pateira que eu já falei já
sendo parreira falou ó canal desta vez
vai fazer de melhorar o quadro
aí entra na boca e outro tanto faz
aqui a boca tem mais cura dessas
internas quando a gente está falido que
tem a ver com matheus na integridade
manter uma abertura que a gente nunca
conheceu antes hoje sábado a gente vai
encontrar essa mulher que a gente é que
a gente nunca tem 61 anos e para poder
conseguir entender a fronteira fim a
gente e do nosso potencial
a gente teve ultrapassar tudo o que é
habitual
tudo que ordinário tudo o que é comum no
dia a dia porque a essência ou que o
japão também de memória celular da fêmea
que já faliu há tantas gerações e por
milhões de anos que está segurando e
mantendo é garantida a reprodução da
espécie
essa fêmea não monta uma geração para a
outra então quando uma mulher no ano
2005 vai cair vai cair aquela mulher que
foi dando essa lembrança memórias a
sabedoria corporal
chico uma garantia
gs então é muito importante a gente
entender que a nossa sexualidade é uma
fonte de energia de força e mensurar a
gente não tem como medir é o porque uma
mulher é capaz de ficar dias e noites
sem dormir pode ficar assim comer pode
vender modificar contado entre uma e
outra votação e então que ele estiver
respirando e pelo menos dependendo em
tomando alguma coisa para sustentar dia
ela foi o detalhe ela pode sair ela vai
lembrar de como pai vi que quando o erro
da vida ela vai nascer que a gente
aprendeu a andar
são aquelas qualidades que a gente
precisa para ser a melhor marca que tem
a gente aprende paciência a gente
aprende perceber nossa gente aprende
entrega a gente aprenda não jogar porque
haja demorou demais para é demorou
demais
de repente você então não vai mais
querer ter um filho não a gente tem sim
a gente tem que aprender a aprimorar
essas qualidades enquanto o filho nasce
a gente tem a capacidade de ficar
acordado à noite é lamentável
é momento de total nada de ficar
cuidando do filho porque cuidar de um
filho e de cinco filhos de 15 e que
antes as mulheres tinham os meus filhos
não é uma coisa fácil
o sexo feminino a gente tem que lembrar
novamente que sexual muito forte e eu
gostaria como feminista que eu sou
jamais destruir o outro porque eu sei o
quanto que o homem mulher fazendo uma
parceria biológica uma parceria amorosa
com o cada um dos filhos da gente
precisa da mãe do pai
a sociedade precisa de energia masculina
tanto quanto da feminina
mas eu gostaria de colocar na qualidade
energética da mulher porque o propósito
aqui ea gente encaminhar nossa sociedade
para uma eqüidade de gênero que vai ter
repercussão nas políticas nas economias
nas situações de indignidade de saúde
nem de crescimento pessoal dos membros
da sociedade ea energia do felino
não é só porque eu mulher eu quero
sentir que a itália não é porque quando
a gente for lembrar que o instinto
materno de nós mulheres e primo de
olinda
o instinto que é acompanhado com aquela
essência novamente que não tem palavras
para descrever mas que a gente tem aqui
uma palavra que funciona bem que morre
o amor é a essência matéria
se a gente puder voltar a recuperar essa
força essa dignidade e honra essa grande
admiração pela força fórmula do felino
na nossa sociedade
a gente vai provavelmente
ele as mudanças no político no suas e
econômico que mostra ser muito mais a
morosidade a gente como mulher sabe
conciliar muito bem a gente acha a forma
de um filho outro que são diferentes que
não ocorra
procure e ache aquela forma legal
dina amoroso e justa a gente poder vir
juntos respeitando namíbia nossa
[Aplausos]